على كل حال سالنا الفتيات في مصر هل يمكن
ان تطلبي يد شاب للزواج
[موسيقى]
مينفعش لازم دايما الولد هو اللي يطلب
الايد الايد البنت اصلا لان احنا مجتمعنا
اصلا المفروض يعني البلد هو المسؤول اكتر
في الحوارات دي في الوقت الحالي او في ظل
الجيل اللي احنا فيه ممكن المواضيع بتتطور
شويه ممكن اه يحصل كده مش هتبقى حلوه لو
بنت عشان ان يعني ممكن هي تترفد لو هو مش
بيحبها انما الولد هيترفض عادي ممكن ان
انا اعبر عن مشاعري شويه في افعال ممكن
شويه برده في كلام بس لا مش ان انا اروح
اقول له حاجه بصراحه هو اللي يجي المفروض
مش انا اللي اروح هو لو انا معجبه بيه
ممكن اصارحه بس مش هاروح اتقدم له يعني لو
هي معجبه بيه تروح تقول له اه انا عايزه
ارتبط بيك وممكن نتجوز او ممكن نتعرف ببعض
ولو في نصيب يكملوا مع بعض اه لا طبعا ما
ينفعش يعني المفروض هو اللي يجي معروفه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]